last week Donald Trump did away with
Obama era protections for transgender
students that allowed them to do allowed
them to use whichever bathroom they
identified with okay this is something
that should have been totally
uncontroversial when it happened but as
you probably remember it caused many
right-wingers to fly off the handle in a
rage many Republicans oppose letting
transgender people choose their own
bathroom saying that it'll lead to
sexual assault it'll lead to sex crimes
even though there's no evidence
whatsoever for that here's a fascinating
little tidbit more Republican lawmakers
have been arrested for sexual misconduct
in bathrooms than transgender people
have three Republicans I will tell you
about we will start with John Hinson who
was in 1981 arrested for having oral sex
in the US House of Representatives
bathroom with a male staffer five years
earlier he was also arrested for
exposing himself to an undercover agent
that same year I'm sorry then that gets
us to Larry Craig he might remember
Larry wide stance in the airport
bathroom Craig who was arrested it's
amazing but it's been 10 years in 2007
for lewd conduct after presumably
propositioning an undercover police
officer for sex in a Minneapolis Airport
and the same year Bob Allen a Florida
State Representative was arrested for
paying an undercover police officer 20
dollars to allow him to perform oral sex
on him in a bathroom at a public park so
throughout US history there's a grand
total of zero transgender people that
have been arrested for a sexual crime in
a bathroom I'd call it irony but it's
actually way worse this is now now I
mean how much taxpayer money at various
local state and federal levels has been
spent on debating and trying to impact
who can use which which bathroom and it
is just not an issue Republicans some of
them anyway say they want to prevent
transgender people from using the
bathroom they want to use because men
might pretend to be transgender in order
to get access to a woman's
bathroom for deviant reasons there's
also no record of that happening in the
United States although Mike Huckabee
once said if when he was in high school
he would have been allowed to say he was
a woman to go check out girls in the
girls locker room that he would have so
really we have Republican lawmakers
saying that they would have done this
and they're not transgender but we don't
actually have any evidence that this is
a real problem and and further how would
that be prevented or deterred by the law
anyway I mean if you want to dress like
the opposite sex in order to infiltrate
a bathroom to commit a crime there's a
good chance you're going to do it
regardless of what the transgender
bathroom laws are not to mention that we
have laws against sexual assault it's
illegal in all bathrooms by all genders
against all genders and sexes regardless
of who is allowed in the bathroom but to
be a little more serious there's
probably some Republicans that are
projecting their own sexual ambivalence
with their anti LGBT rhetoric we've had
dozens and dozens of committed lifelong
anti LGBT Republicans who have who it
turns out are actually members of the
LGBT community themselves and that's a
real issue I know that sometimes it gets
caricature eyes it obviously doesn't
apply to everybody but it's a real issue
issue and it applies to dozens and
dozens of Republican politicians